[Music]
justin theroux breaks his silence for a
heartwarming cause which is harder than
you might think 10 days after he and
jennifer aniston announced their split
the 46 year old actor is taking to
social media for the first time to help
some adorable four-legged friends find
home on Sunday throw instagrammed
several truly adorable photos with cuz
Lee pups writing another very inspiring
visit with the incredible people and
pups at austin pets alive i highly
recommend going in and getting your nose
bit by a toothless baby pitbull these
two aren't yet ready to go but when they
are go get'em last year the mute star
donated $10,000 to the charity after
winning a game of hot hands on ellen i
love and i used to go and cut their dogs
when i would go when i was shooting in
austin good for you they're great it's
no secret that the RO has a soft spot
for rescue pups correct
so he's fantastic he even tried to get
his wanderlust co-star Malin Akerman to
adopt during this interview with ET you
should rescue a dog we had a rescue dog
but we ended up we had him for about a
year but we could not rescue him from
his personality
now despite Justin's adorable post a
source tells ET that he is going to lay
low now and just try to recalibrate
following his separation from Aniston
[Music]